前髪長くないですか私は今まで使ってきたとっておきのアイテム
[音楽]
鮮度をドリルですこの電動踊りでも無限の可能性非見てると思うんですよ
まあ今までも動画で何回も使ってきたんですけどもこの子は本当に役に立つって僕思っ
たんですけどもこの電動ドリル何がすごいかっていうとやはり a 新緑だと思いまし
た何度もごめんねこんなんでいいんですけど本当にここの回転力以上ここからもうここ
まで上がりますからね
相撲外部でほんとどうだと伝わらないと思うんですけどマジで速いからねあそび心だっ
て生まれで親だってこれ両面テープ付たらもう
無くなっちゃうからね
このすごい新緑を使って今回取ることしようと思いますうーんそう
クラッカーですなんか擦ってご引っ張んなきゃいけないんでしょこの日もこの鬼門いっ
ぱると音が鳴るとこの日一般地から普通に人間がね構成でもなるわけないですよ
これからいない侵略だって下がっチョコワイパーになりそうて怖かったさすがにに
竜の力とこれがいねえ全力がクラッカーもなりませんよでもこれをひょっとしたらこの
くらいかひょっとしたらこの最高速の電動ドリルのここにくっつけて回すと遠心力大で
クラッカーなるんじゃないかと思いまして今回はちょっと a 侵略だけを使って
クラッカーを鳴らしてみようと思います
これ本当に貼っていったクラッカー会の増資変わりますからね
まあとりあえず1件軽くつけてみるよ遠心力続きです飛んで行くと僕は見た
うんぱこれを予測していたよちょっと強めに飛べてみますこれだけ多分取れないくらい
だと思います mature
[音楽]
[拍手]
ha
言われた
描くねー
[音楽]
持った
立っ
[音楽]
意欲が強すぎてアブデルから飛んでっちゃう
これはいけますとかなり頑丈につけてみたねこれ当たるいくと思います
[拍手]
さあ
ブーブー今まで完全に証明されましたヘッダー新緑でクロスあのペター分かりまして僕
は国家路線網なるほどっ
あったんで振っ買ってこう引っ張る抜きの方にしか飛ばないんじゃないですかアレで
電動デールにたくさんクラッカーをつけると改定しててもう全方向へ180度全部に
食らった飛ぶことができるんでもうねみんなを祝うことができますこれで180度に
いる周りの人みんなを幸せにできる名砲兵発車クラッカーが完成することができるかも
知れませんちょっと前濃度0の先っぽにクラッカーでも付けてみよう
ん
うんうん
うんうんああああああ
ああああああ
さあこちら托鉢ジーノぜひ方に発車暗く悲しいでございますさあこういう感じですね
全部前こと飛ばないようにうまいこと貼り付けて前方向に向かってクラック発射する
なっておりますこれを打つとも僕の場合180度全部方向にクラッカーが飛んで行くと
いうわけで多少の嫌がらせみたいになりますというわけで今回の動画右手だけでもう全
方向から
とってめでたく降りましょう以上 cracker チェーンの革命児
はじめしゃちょーでした3
1ああああああああ
出社結論や薪車かぷあっちゃうわっ
ふーんこれですごいよしまってよフィギュア
[音楽]
はあああああ
yeah yeah
dea
car
ana あああっ
はあああああ
はぁ